la pêche au thon continue Évelyne Thomas
toujours en danger
[Applaudissements]
Stéphane Guillon
Jason
Stéphane c'est qu'on peut pas parler
politique veille d'élection vous savez
j'en parlerai pas d'accord quand vous
écoute quand même
élections législative en Belgique
Yves le terme remporte 31% des voix sans
on a le droit d'en parler tout le monde
s'en fout mais alors à ce propos je vous
ai fait trois infos on s'en fout mais on
peut en parler Stéphane Bern adore le
sport hippique 9 suisses sur 10
possèdent un téléphone portable
par essilton refuse de déféquer aux
toilettes voilà en prison
société Clichy interdit les mini moto ça
c'est dégueulasse pour les gens de
petite taille parce que eux c'est leur
moto normal Mimie Mathy ou d'autres mais
bon soyez
la pêche au thon continue Évelyne Thomas
toujours en danger
une info gala Sylvie Vartan avec le
temps je deviens plus fragile c'est
normal Sylvie c'est l'ostéoporose
sport selon la société Philips se raser
c'est comme piloter une Formule 1 et ça
c'est qu'en Franck Ribéry se rase
en tout cas
c'est un super rasoir Amanda lire la
commande est demain pour la fête des
pères bonne fête Amanda
télévision à Paris Emmanuel Chain
organise le premier salon du petit écran
plusieurs stands le Jean-Luc Delarue
le Sébastien Cauet
le Michel Drucker
le Thierry Ardisson
et enfin très attendu le standard Pascal
Sevran
on termine ce salon avec une nouveauté
qui devrait intéresser André Manoukian
une nouvelle star à l'envers on vote
pour que des chanteurs connus
redeviennent anonymes alors ça
donnerait ça oui tu t'appelles comment
Matthieu Mireille vas-y on t'écoute stop
Manu catcher tu en penses quoi écoute
Mireille si j'ai envie d'écouter Piaf je
me fais pas chier je vais acheter
l'album à la FNAC physiquement tu es
coiffé comme un playmobil en plus tu es
la chanteuse préférée de Stéphane Bern
ça fait trois raisons que tu dégages
suivante
Régine Marianne commentaire pardon je
suis très ému j'ai des petites larmes
est devenu chanter dans l'état où tu es
une chanson de Madonna en plus
manu a eu très peur que comme elle tu
balances ta culotte au public tu l'as
pas fait merci fais juste gaffe quand tu
bouges au fil de ta personne
Carla Bruni allez-y Marianne tu en
penses quoi j'ai rien entendu
moi je trouve que tu as une voix sublime
sublime sublime sublime le fait que tu
fasses 85 60 86 ça donne à ta voix un
grain extraordinaire je vais te laisser
mon portable qu'on en parle
tranquillement ce soir à la maison par
contre quand tu arrives tape sur
l'interphone avec le point sinon je
t'entendrai pas
merci à la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu